[Música]
Saludos cordiales desde París un placer
que estén nuevamente en nuestra compañía
como siempre les traemos algunas de las
noticias del mundo cultural en Francia y
se lo contamos ya mismo
conoceremos a la autora Argentina sole
Otero y su novela gráfica naftalina un
relato íntimo y familiar premiado en el
Festival Internacional de la historieta
de angulema llega a los cines franceses
la película El agua de la española Elena
López riera una cinta sobre las mujeres
de un pueblo y el poder de los relatos y
en nuestra Crónica musical conversaremos
con las exuberantes y belli las mellizas
Franco cubanas regresan a los escenarios
con un nuevo disco que celebra su amor
de hermanas y sus raíces
[Música]
abrimos nuestro programa de hoy con un
artista Argentina premiada aquí en
Francia se llama sole Otero es autora de
historietas y fue distinguida por su
novela gráfica naftalina Melissa barra
pudo conversar con ella
en naftalina sole Otero nos acoge en una
casa familiar Argentina un hogar en el
que convergen dos épocas la de Rocío un
estudiante bonaerense en el año 2001 y
la de su abuela fallecida Vilma
inmigrante italiana cuyo recuerdo aún
habita el espacio doméstico en la
historia de un montón de mujeres que
estaban adentro de la casa y que seguían
cargando todo lo que pasaba afuera de
esa casa y de todo ese contexto social
pero de otra manera que quizás tiene
menos relatos
y bueno y en particular también porque
es un poco de alguna manera la historia
de mi propia abuela y me interesaba
contar esos conflictos de ella lo que la
llevó a volverse la persona que era
intentando entenderla y eso también
termina siendo parte de intentar
entender ese contexto en el que ella
creció y vivió que hoy por ejemplo yo me
pueda dedicar a hacer historietas no
hubiera sido posible sin esa generación
de abuelas naftalina no es solo el drama
de un hogar también es el relato de toda
una generación Argentina desde la
migración europea hasta la crisis
económica pasando por la dictadura o las
normas sociales y religiosas hay como
una diferencia muy puntual en el tema de
la relación de la mujer con la política
y con el acto político en la época de la
abuela donde la misma abuela rechazaba
eso porque lo sentía como una especie de
Invasión y la actitud de la nieta hacia
involucrarse con ese con eso que está
fuera y creo que también me parece que
tiene que ver con un poco con esta idea
como de las constelaciones familiares y
de
que entender lo que pasó en generaciones
anteriores en la familia de uno ayuda
aunque sean diferentes las historias a
tratar de remendar un poco lo que está
pasando en el presente sobre Otero
recibió este año el premio del público
Fox televisión el festival de angulema
la Meca Mundial de la historieta
[Música]
les traemos a continuación noticias del
reconocido festival de cine de Canes a
realizarse como todos los años en el mes
de mayo el certamen de la Riviera
francesa ha escogido al director sueco
Rubén para presidir el Jurado Que
examinará las películas de la
competencia a sus 48 años Rubén es lo
que puede llamarse un habichue de la
caseta presentado cinco de sus seis
películas en Canes y ganado dos veces la
palma de oro la máxima recompensa del
festival para la mejor película La
primera vez fue en 2017 con the Square y
la segunda el año pasado por su comedia
sin filtro y ya que hablamos de cine
esta semana llega a Francia a la cinta
española el agua un drama fantástico
cargado de relatos y supersticiones
nosotros conocimos a la directora de
esta película cuando mi abuela me dice
que se bañaban aquí en el río una región
en España sus tierras agrícolas sus
mujeres y sus miedos eso es lo que
explora con brío el agua primer
largometraje de la española Elena López
riera en ese pueblo las mujeres
desaparecen después de una inundación y
la protagonista de mecer la próxima
víctima del agua según una creencia
popular su directora nos contó Por qué
abordó este tema en su ópera prima yo
había hecho mis tres cortometrajes
anteriores también ahí y era como la
continuación natural de seguir
explorando una herencia no que llevo en
mis espaldas que me ha nutrido que me ha
regalado un montón de cosas que me ha
constituido pero que también pesa mucho
hay una mitología y una especie de
leyenda que dice que el río se desborda
porque se enamora de una mujer y como no
puede tenerla pues lo lleva todo para
adelante y genera pues desgracias
catástrofes y yo me he criado con esa
con esos cuentos
el agua puede leerse como un
cuestionamiento al patriarcado y al rol
de las mujeres víctimas y a la vez
perpetuadoras de los estigmas como
muchas veces esas leyendas esos cuentos
populares son las mismas mujeres las que
las han transmitido no Entonces esto es
algo que a mí me inquieta me perturba lo
cuestiono tampoco es un juicio ni
muchísimo menos Pero por otro lado lo
que me fascina es que fuerza encuentra
muchas de esas mujeres hablo de ellas
porque son sobre todo las mujeres que me
han acompañado y que he encontrado a lo
largo de esta película donde encuentran
la fuerza para seguir con todo no
Entonces al mismo tiempo que es una
herencia y un peso que vamos
transmitiendo nos y transmitiendo [__]
la fuerza no de poder sobrevivir a ello
Es que sabes lo que pasa que aunque te
joda Elena López riera da voz a las
mujeres de su pueblo y escudriña las
relaciones entre diversas generaciones
dentro de una misma familia
hay violencia en el amor entre una madre
y una hija existe esa violencia no se
habla mucho de ello porque parece un
tema tabú pero es que a veces es
doloroso me imagino que mi madre me ha
querido matar mil veces entonces a mí y
yo a ella por supuesto No no pero claro
o sea por supuesto entonces hay algo ahí
que porque no podemos hablar de es de la
complejidad y de la fragilidad no
también se habla mucho de las mujeres
fuertes valientes como Bueno sí claro No
nos queda otra pero [__] Y si somos a
veces frágiles y tenemos miedo y no
sabemos cómo hacer las cosas y a mí hay
algo de esa fragilidad y en la relación
entre esas tres mujeres que me
interesaba mucho también intentar no sé
si lo consigo pero por lo menos intento
acercarme a eso no va a salir bien
[Música]
pasamos ahora nuestra Crónica musical
Natalia Olivares nos presenta hoy a un
Dúo Franco cubano las hermanas y belli
que han conquistado el público francés
Con un concierto en la mítica sala
Olimpia y ahora se alistan para irse de
gira por Estados Unidos Hola Natalia
Hola María Carolina y las hermanas y
bellas son conocidas por tener una
infinidad de recursos rítmicos musicales
y culturales ellas gracias a ellas la
canción francesa ahora se escribe con el
espíritu Yoruba y suena así
[Música]
y como lo decías María Carolina las
hermanas y bellies conquistaron al
público francés en un gran espectáculo
en gran show en la mítica sala el
Olimpia ahora se preparan para presentar
ese nuevo disco spel 31 a otro tipo de
público el público de Estados Unidos una
gira que las llevará a ciudades como Los
Ángeles San Francisco Nueva York o Miami
pero antes de salir nos concedieron una
entrevista aquí en París
mi gemela y es parte del grupo que
tenemos que se llama Ebay y Naomi días
es mi gemela y también es la segunda
parte es el ritmo la parte rítmica del
grupo que tenemos que se llama Ebay
[Música]
y veis significa gemelos en orugas el
Yoruba cubano que viene de los yorubas
en Nigeria
en Nigeria se dice y pechi pero en Cuba
cuando los esclavos fueron deportados a
Cuba la lengua cambió porque era de oído
no Y entonces cambió y ahora se dice
[Música]
eBay
las hermanas Las mellizas y llevan 10
años reivindicando sus raíces a través
de este gran proyecto musical un
proyecto ligado directamente a su
familia Pero sobre todo un legado de su
padre el artista cubano conocido anga
Díaz que participó en grupos como los
irakeres o Buena Vista Social Club y
para recordarles a nuestro público
Miguel áncadilla fue un percusionista
legendario fue quien desarrolló el toque
con cinco tumbadoras introdujo también
los estilos el ritmo caribeño en estilos
musicales exactamente Y esa afiliación
es el legado son indisociables de ese
proyecto musical Las y pero tampoco su
cultura y sus raíces francesas
ritmos que vienen de la cultura de
nuestro padre que era Juana pero hay la
cultura francesa está muy presente en
nuestras canciones quizás se se nota
menos pero aprendimos la música en
Francia
porque Nacimos en Francia el hecho que
las letras es algo muy importante para
nosotros es algo muy francés también
como en francés
[Música]
este disco spel 31 es un disco muy
espiritual y boca los muertos pero
también otros temas son tratados como la
injusticia o la rabia como lo contaron
ellas mismas
no es tanto la violencia más es la rabia
la rabia que uno siente cuando uno ve
injusticia el dolor y lo que queremos
hacer es que la gente lo saque entonces
cada vez que cantamos esas canciones en
los conciertos hacemos creamos un un
como un universo donde la gente puede
gritar y cantar y que se saque esa rabia
que tiene que tenemos todos en nuestro
cuerpo no y es muy importante para
nosotros hablar de eso Pero también ese
disco es un disco de celebración
celebramos a nuestra música a los diez
años de eBay celebramos a nuestra
hermandad celebramos a nuestra madre
celebramos a nuestros ancestros
celebramos a la magia que tenemos todos
en nuestros cuerpos celebramos el amor
esas cosas son si es un disco que
hicimos para curarnos el alma no después
de una pandemia que todo el mundo sabe
cuál es
[Risas]
[Música]
el 31 un disco de celebraciones con
muchos invitados diferentes de
diferentes Horizontes como en esta
canción lavender and Roses que contó con
la participación de la gran yora Miss
bueno Natalie vamos a terminar este
programa justamente con ese tema la
banda si rosas de las Y muchísimas
gracias por habernos presentado a este
Dúo Franco cubano y a ustedes por su
sintonía muchísimas gracias y hasta la
próxima
[Música]